[Music]
hey what's going on first we feast fans
it's Sean Evans coming at you with a
quick State of the Union regarding hot
ones season 4 premieres next week that's
right just a quick little break little
vacation 4th of July I had my fun but
now it's back in the hot seat battle and
wings battle and hot sauces and
interviewing your favorite celebrities
and you know what that means
it's out with the old and in with the
new when it comes to the hot sauces and
as you can see here there's a lot of new
going on right here this is like the NBA
draft of hot sauces the official season
for hot sauce unveiling let's start at
the beginning and it's no longer
sriracha no big deal is now Valentina
black label no big deal Valentina is a
Mexican restaurant table hot sauce it's
delicious it's one of my favorites and
I'm happy that we could finally make a
place for it on the table at number two
we've replaced Tabasco whoa whoa whoa
what's going on this is crystal everyone
knows Tabasco we wanted to do something
a little bit different pay homage to the
Louisiana legend that is crystal those
who know know those who don't know we'll
find out soon at number three secret
aardvark habanero sauce talk to anyone
in Portland they will swear by this hot
sauce it's great on everything
especially Wings in our hot sauce sensei
over at Heat inist hot ones fans know
him as Noah he swears by this stuff says
it'll sometimes use an entire bottle on
a single pizza that's coming from Noah
we've said okay where do you want to put
it let's save a spot let's save a spot
it's coming in at number three at number
four we've swapped out one Queen Majesty
for another it's out with the coffee
it's in with the scotch bonnet and
ginger to the hot ones trivia heads out
there this is the first scotch bonnet
based sauce that we've ever had on the
show big day for hot sauce big day for
hot ones somebody start the parade at
number five hot ones fiery Chipotle
holding its place what do you think
we're going to get rid of it give me a
break
at number six dirty dicks very
aggressive brand name but amazing hot
sauce out of Vermont probably the best
pound-for-pound chicken sauce on the
mark
it it complements the hot ones hot sauce
nicely with a little fruit blend in
there you have bananas
you have mangoes you have pineapple and
then it has that habanero finish amazing
at number seven torchbearer zombie
apocalypse holding its ground at number
eight the bomb hot sauce too many good
reactions so it's holding strong at
number eight and before we move on a
quick moment of silence for Mad Dog 357
thank you for everything that you've
done for hot ones everyone shut up okay
this is Blair's mega death sauce with
liquid rage it used to be our hottest
sauce it's now our second hottest sauce
BAM we have a new king of the mountain
this is the last dab a new addition to
the hot ones family you'll be learning a
lot more about this sauces season four
unfolds but suffice to say we went to a
legend for the new number 10 hot when
fans known as smokin edy curry smoke and
edy has bred a new pepper hotter than
the Carolina Reaper and never seen
before you're hearing about it first
it's called pepper X and there is a
boatload of pepper acts and the new the
last dab number 10 sauce what does
pepper act do to your biology exactly no
one really knows but who better to serve
as guinea pigs than me week over week
and high-profile entertainers we have a
lot to lose by eating it and quite
frankly not much to gain we're working
furiously to get this sauce to market so
unfortunately you cannot buy it quite
yet but soon you'll be able to the rest
of these though if you want to play at
home you should be able to get no
problem stay tuned for an announcement
soon on the last dab you know we're
going to keep you guys informed you'll
be the first to know
well there you have it it's the season
for lineup revealed and there's one
final gift to the hot ones fans out
there we're going to play an emotional
tug at the heartstrings one shining
moment montage for season three I hope
you have a box of tissues ready thank
you to the hot one fans out there who've
written with us through season one
through season two now through season
three and into season four roll the tape
and cameras right there hey what's going
on everybody so first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot one the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wing I don't know why I'm doing this
from being totally honest turn off those
three got some lag to it interesting hot
sauce it plays tricks it feels kind of
good it's a little I gotta miss joint
I'm the mayor of flavortown a flood of
all the animal testicles that you I'm
really trying to keep it together right
now I'm not sure how this turns out from
quite minor glasses there is a human
being I meet you I'm Gloria I'm playing
like a hound but the YAG is I'd say some
hot wings
even though I will sing wandering
minstrel ie ie ie a bread baker a good
Baker a name that comes up over the
course of this show have you been on the
show not yet I'm Brett Baker and today
I'm the host pop bread that was for you
Thank You Russell
grant I love you too are you sure you're
gonna do what are you doing why are you
doing that why are you shaking it like
that oh I'm sorry non-fire to make
camera other people know what you have
going on here the truth yourself well
let them tell you dick
supports fine arts teacher kitchen cook
I'm not going to tell you to go get a
tampon soak it in the hottest hot sauce
and stick it up your butt saying don't
do that
[Music]
good I'm ready no cover hot sauce